[Music]
well tuned to is easy to love
it's colorful in quirky and unafraid to
be different and it's consistently a
blast to play as far as shooters go it's
unique movement mechanics stand out and
make each magic sighting and all the
logistics of its multiplayer aren't
perfect
splatoon too is a vibrant and exuberant
sequel with enough fresh additions and
changes to set it apart from the
original
like the first games we'll tune to stars
human squid hybrids called Inklings your
weapons shoot or sometimes fling ink and
you can instantly change into your squid
form and spin through ink puddles to
reload swimming also has a stealth
element to it since you're harder to see
and faster and therefore better equipped
for surprise attacks
you can also ink walls and swim up them
in squid form which adds to your
verticality and matches in the standard
multiplayer mode turf war you're tasked
with inking more of the map and your
opponents will also splatting them to
limit their progress multiplayer is
undoubtedly the main draw splatoon - but
both new and returning players should
absolutely try the new and improved
single-player mode before jumping into
any matches unlike in the first game
where you could only use the standard
splatter shotgun in the campaign so
tuned to serves as a fantastic
introduction to all the basic weapon
types you'll have access to and it's
much more robust with collectables that
require a sharp eye defined and creative
platforming challenges that really
showcase how unique splatoon two's
movement is for the shooter genre and
while it starts out of it basic each
level builds on the last and requires
clever application of your knowledge to
complete grinding on Rails while
shooting targets then switching to your
squid form and successfully landing a
tricky jump is satisfying not just
because it's fun and cool but because it
really feels like you've mastered
splatoon twos and new mechanics
unfortunately not all of the
single-player campaigns lessons made it
into the multiplayer most notably rail
grinding which is the standout from
single-player isn't possible on more
8-hours rails
that in particular feels like a missed
opportunity especially since that map is
returning for the first game however
getting to use a wide variety of weapons
in single-player makes the transition to
multiplayer easier and subtle tweaks to
weapons and gear like faster movement
with the roller at a layer of new
strategy for veteran players
the only multiplayer mode for non ranked
matches is turf war which is
consistently so much fun that only
having one casual mode isn't really a
problem covering the most ground with
your ink is a simple enough concept but
skillful movement well-timed
inking in the right strategy for your
weapon all work together to make each
match exciting there are some wrinkles
with the logistics of these regular
battles there's no way to change your
weapon once in a lobby so you're stuck
with whatever team composition you get
and you can't guarantee you'll be on the
same team as any friends who join your
Lobby but as the most laid-back of the
multiplayer options its quick games and
random team assignments make it easy to
jump in and out and have fun without too
much pressure it might be frustrating
when your team of randoms doesn't seem
to know what they're doing but the
fast-paced struggle to cover turf with
your team's ink is as exhilarating as
ever
ranked battles returned with tower
control Rainmaker and splat zones each
mode is similar to game types you might
be familiar with and other team shooters
tower control consists of escorting a
tower to a goal Rainmaker is like
reverse capture the flag and splat zones
is a lot like Call of Duty's domination
mode
unfortunately the lobbies for ranked
matches haven't been populated enough
for us to play them ahead of launch but
based on our experience with the first
game we can expect these modes to work
essentially the same way
splatoon zinc mechanics make these notes
feel different from other games and the
focus on specific objectives is great
for competitive players who want
something more than the informal
structure of turf war
the biggest problems with the original
splatoon's multiplayer were limited
matchmaking any lack of voice chat which
made team strategy extremely cumbersome
and difficult while regular battles
still lack shooter matchmaking mainstays
like parties there's a new mode called
League battle that lets you group up
with either one or three friends and
play together in a more competitive
environment League battles include the
same modes as ranked but don't affect
your solo rank which is a great option
if your skills aren't quite in line with
your friends combined with a pin abled
voice chat on a mobile device which
admittedly is a less than elegant
solution League that'll alleviate some
of the complaints about the first game
without changing all of multiplayer for
those who just want to play for fun or
roll solo there's also a new co-op mode
called salmon run that lets you play
alongside one to three friends in a
horde environment it's surprisingly
challenging and requires more strategy
and finesse than turf war by far even on
lower difficulties my groups struggled
against mini bosses that require
specific strategies to take out they're
less threatening than the single-player
bosses but hard to deal with in high
volumes successfully clearing the waves
was satisfying knowing that we had to
have worked well as a team in order to
survive in addition to the updated
single-player campaign this is another
mode that shows up what's so great about
splatoon 2 is unique gameplay in ways
that PvP multiplayer doesn't
at first glance splatoon - seems very
similar to the first game but all the
small changes and even the bigger ones
in single-player and League battles make
for a fresh take on the already unique
shooter if you played a lot of the
original the sequel has enough to keep
you coming back and if you're new to the
game it's a fantastic place to jump in
[Music]
[Music]